ah oui Bruno retaille on va commencer
par évoquer cette affaire de
l'opposition au Méga bassine de
Sainte-Soline est-ce que cette affaire a
été bien gérée par le gouvernement
notamment par le ministre de l'Intérieur
qui a parlé des côtes terroristes en
parlant des militants écologistes en
tout cas c'est
ultra violent ça a été bien géré par les
forces de l'ordre et je veux le rendre
hommage le problème c'est que le
gouvernement et notamment Emmanuel
Macron a fait une faute originelle en
donnant raison aux hadistes à
Notre-Dame-des-Landes on l'aura donné un
permis de casser un permis de casser y
compris des policiers ou des gendarmes
c'est de là en réalité que vient le
débordement aussi de violence notamment
sur les aides puisque à
Notre-Dame-des-Landes tout près d'ici
alors qu'il y avait eu un référendum
alors ce qui est alors qu'il y avait
plus de 179 décisions de justice qui
allaient toutes dans le même sens le
gouvernement monsieur Macron a fait un
clin d'oeil à ses hadistes uniquement
pour donner raison à l'éphémère ministre
de l'écologie Monsieur Hulot on va
parler également de l'immigration
l'autre sujet du jour puisque Gérald de
maintenant et le ministre du Travail
Olivier du socle on fait des annonces
les grandes lignes du futur projet de
loi immigration notamment sur la
question des obligations de quitter le
territoire français est-ce que vous
pensez que les mesures annoncées par
Gérard de Darmanin vont permettre
d'exécuter plus efficacement c'est
décisions non pour l'instant je crois
pas c'est certainement pas en inscrivant
sur un fichier des personnes recherchées
que on aura demain des résultats en
revanche en revanche je le dis
solennellement aujourd'hui je pense que
le projet tel qui se dessine ce sera
encore plus d'immigration puisque on se
propose régulariser avec des titres de
séjour pour le travail sur des métiers
en tension mais vous savez
qu'aujourd'hui toute la France est une
zone géographique concernée par des
métiers en tension et puis maintenant
tous les métiers tous les métiers sont
en tension donc c'est une ouverture des
vins de même que si demain pour celles
et ceux qui sont candidats aux droits
d'asile on leur dit vous pouvez
travailler ça veut dire simplement que
si n'obtiennent pas leur droit d'asile
ils pourront rester au titre d'un séjour
pour le travail donc c'est bien plus
d'immigration au bout du compte mais
est-ce que ça ne permet pas cette
immigration choisie qui est d'ailleurs
avait été souhaitée par Nicolas Sarkozy
à l'époque de régler certains problèmes
économiques toutes en intégrant mieux
mais c'est une règle rien du tout
puisque on en a déjà aujourd'hui un
certain nombre de résultats de chiffres
puisque le chômage de masse touche deux
fois plus de personnes immigrées qu'il
touche des Français il y a des millions
de Français déjà de nationaux qui sont
au chômage ça veut dire qu'on se résigne
à les faire revenir sur le marché du
travail de l'emploi ça veut dire qu'on
se résigne à ne pas les former
correctement à ne pas leur donner des
compétences professionnelles qui leur
permettraient de s'insérer
économiquement ce texte immigration il
devrait arriver en janvier d'abord au
Sénat ça veut dire que pour l'instant le
groupe LR n'est pas prêt à le voter
non alors on attend le texte évidemment
mais les signaux qui sont donnés
aujourd'hui sont beaucoup trop faibles
je pense que c'est tout simplement parce
que il y a pas de majorité vraiment dans
la macronie sur ce sujet là ils sont
très très divisés Bruno Retailleau pour
finir un mot sur la campagne à la
présidence du parti à la République
puisque vous êtes candidat vous avez
déclaré la marque les républicains est
morte alors quelle marque pour faire
renaître le parti et quel nouveau nom
c'est pas une question de non c'est pas
une question de siège c'est pas
seulement une question de marque c'est
une question beaucoup plus profonde moi
je pense que il faudra redonner notre
mouvement ce parti aux militants ce que
je veux c'est vraiment non seulement le
redonner la parole mais leur donner un
bulletin de vote pour que les grands
orientations puissent être tranchées
démocratiquement pourquoi parce que je
suis certain que si on redonne la parole
aux militants alors le courage sera au
rendez-vous parce qu'un militant ça met
toujours toujours ses convictions au
niveau et au dessus des petits calculs
politiciens merci beaucoup Bruno
retailleux d'avoir répondu à mes
questions
[Musique]